voilà françois mitterrand sa part de
mystère ce qui peut apparaître
surprenant pour celui qui a pourtant
exercé le plus long mandat présidentiel
de la vème république
on l'a vu un homme hanté par la mort
affaibli par la maladie mais soucieux de
peser jusqu au bout par bout du pouvoir
sans doute aussi par goût de la
postérité il ya du romanesque bien sûr
chez ce passionné des belles lettres une
part de mysticisme aussi chez cet homme
qui a reçu une éducation catholique
quelle trace les styles aujourd'hui dans
la pratique présidentielle c'est le
point de départ de notre débat après ce
film mitterrand à bout portant de jean
philippe djian et pour approfondir à
présent j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir sur
ce plateau dominique bertinotti bonjour
monsieur vous êtes historienne vous avez
été ministre déléguée à la famille dans
le gouvernement de jean marc ayrault
vous avez été l'archiviste de françois
mitterrand et vous êtes membre de
l'institut françois mitterrand on vous
doit le jour où la gauche s'est perdue
paru aux éditions calmann levy bonjour
avoue michèle cotta journaliste
éditorialiste
on vous donne notamment le monde selon
mitterrand on bat pensée arrière pensée
chez taillandier autrement dit on est au
coeur de notre sujet est avec nous
également pierre favier bonjour vous
avez été pour l' agence france-presse
vous avez suivi françois mitterrand
pendant les deux septennats et il
faisait même de nombreuses occasions
évidemment de converser avec lui le
privilège de déjeuner avec lui jusque
dans les semaines qui ont précédé sa
mort on vous doit un ouvrage de
référence la décennie mitterrand paru en
1990 ou plus proche de nous dix jours en
mai l'histoire de cette alternance de
mai 1981 paru en 2011 aux éditions du
seuil alors vrai qu'on commence par vous
ou michele cotta parce qu'on ressort de
ce film en se disant que inclus on
s'intéresse à françois mitterrand plus
il nous apparaît énigmatique
d'où vient selon vous cette part de
mystère c'est quelqu'un de très
rationnel méditer est aussi quelqu'un de
très irrationnel et de sa volonté autant
qu'eux
remonte dans mon esprit était en
toujours voulu brouiller les pistes sur
lui-même ses amis ne se connaissaient
pas ils les connaissent et les uns après
les autres lots ce qui te sont
rencontrés en 1980 c'était très étonné
tous de voir que jeune femme
andré rousselet ne connaissez pas roland
dumas rebonds
donc il ya toujours eu une volonté
d'aller plus haut donc d'échapper aussi
aux contraintes de la politique et de
mettre un peu de de ciel et d'idées dans
tout ce qui faisait le sou bateau quoi
ils cultivaient cette ambiguïté ce
mystère dominique bertinotti je peux je
reste enfin vous dites me sers moi je
pense que c'était la condition de sa
propre liberté
c'est un homme qui est très très attaché
à sa liberté à sa liberté à la fois
individuelle mais aussi à sa liberté
dans la décision politique qu'il va
apprendre il
il déteste être soumis à la pression de
quiconque de lobby variés et divers et
il veut donc garder cette liberté c'est
inconcevable dans son exercice du
pouvoir que d'être dans une lecture
immédiate par tout le monde que tout le
monde sache tout inconcevable pierre
favier ne pas dévoiler c'était quand
même dire un levier de pouvoir pour lui
oui sans doute françois mitterrand et
comme tout le monde le sait et l'a écrit
depuis longtemps était un homme très
secret qui de se confier
très peu même jusqu'à ses amis les plus
proches comme andré rousselet par
exemple dont on parlait à l'instant il a
côtoyé fréquenté andré rousselet pendant
40 ans et lorsqu'on interrogé andré
reflet à la fin de sa vie en lui disant
qu'est-ce que quelle part
connaissez-vous de françois mitterrand
il disait je les fréquente est gelée vu
presque tous les jours pendant trentaine
d'années et je dois connaître à peu près
10% de la personnalité de françois
mitterrand
c'est à dire c'était un homme qui se
confiait très peu et qui était resté
effectivement très secret est je crois
comme dominique bertinotti pour garder
sa liberté
il se confiait peu et pourtant il
parlait beaucoup vous arrêtez moi vous
avez eu des conversations avec lui alors
il ne disait rien oui donc j'ai eu des
conversations pendant la vingtaine
d'années dans laquelle je les suis
affolé les 14 années à l'elysée puis est
d'abord les quelques années où je le
suivais au ps
et après avoir quitté l'élysée où je les
ai vus à peu près une fois tous les mois
pour déjeuner c'est à dire 5 6 fois
après son départ de l'elysée
là effectivement il parlait mais il
n'était plus l'homme d'état il présidait
la république
il était le président de république
avait quitté le pouvoir depuis quelques
mois et qui est effectivement très
marquée frappé et qui souffrait de la
maladie
peut-être un mot quand même sur ce que
vous avez dit sur les confidences qu'il
distillait ou non et sur ses amitiés
parce que vous avez cité un certain
nombre de ses amis dominique bertinotti
voilà idra le film nous rappelle sa
fidélité à ses amis pierre bergé par le
même d'un culte de la fidélité on entend
des dents dans le film ça se manifestait
comment il y avait un moment à l'elysée
puisque j'ai travaillé trois ans auprès
de lui à l'elysée
il y avait un moment que vous connaissez
tous sur ce plateau qui était la remise
de décorations et je me souviens très
bien il remettait des décorations à des
paysans nivernais et au césium ont eu
droit à un discours d'une humanité d'une
qualité d'une proximité et je pense que
ça tenait au fait que françois
mitterrand n'a jamais oublié ce qu'il
devait dans son dans son parcours
politique justement à la nièvre au
rapport qu'il avait avec
les les citoyens et voilà et ça je pense
que c'est quelque chose qui explique
cette notion de fidélité
il sait ce qu'il doit et à qui le doit
et de quelle façon il peut leur montrer
pierre favier on voit bien il ya un
rapport très intime aux français a de
toutes conditions et sans jeu sans
jamais céder au populisme
oui alors chez mitterrand il n'y avait
jamais de familiarité aussi bien avec
ses amis politiques les dirigeants du
parti socialiste ou des habits industrie
à l'autre
il n'y avait pas de tutoiement et pas
davantage avec eux les paysans dont on
parlait tout à l'heure dans la nièvre
il n'y avait pas de familiarité ben y
avait quand même une forte proximité
entre mitterrand et ses et les gens avec
lesquels il entretenait une relation
d'amitié mais jamais de familiarité j'ai
vu très très peu de vent qui le
fréquentent et même des plus proches de
tutoyer en dehors de bénouville général
de bénouville qui était député gaulliste
de chaban-delmas que le tutoyer et aussi
des quelques heures de ses amis qu'il
avait rencontré pendant sa captivité en
allemagne
c'est à dire peu là et quelques autres
empreintes entre autres cela le tutoyer
mais à part ces quelques exceptions ils
se comptaient sur les sur les sur les
doigts d'une main
tous les autres le vouvoyer vu parler
avec une certaine distance et un certain
respect et mitterrand qui effectivement
été très attentif aux autres qu'ils
pouvaient parler effectivement des
cultures de l'agriculture avec tous ces
gens avec les paysans de saut de son
département d'élection n'avait jamais eu
de relation familière de familiarité
alors il faut qu'on évoque l'un des
autres aspects de ce film qui avait calé
dans passionnera qui est central dans le
film puisque le film retrace les deux
dernières années de sa vie c'est la
maladie c'est le rapport à la mort et
on ressort de ce film en se disant que
françois mitterrand c'est aussi
l'histoire d'un mensonge puisque ce que
le film ne rappelle pas tout à fait mais
enfin c'est il est très très tôt très
tôt au courant de sa maladie et cela
dominique bertinotti
de fait ils le cachent aux français je
ne vois pas comment il aurait pu faire
autrement en katona seulement après
avoir accepté et après il faut aussi se
poser la question et c'est pour ça que
le le terme de mensonges moi je mettrais
plutôt le terme de mission c'est que un
moment donné dans le dans le monde
politique
on a on n'avait aucune réflexion sur ce
qu'est ce que signifiait un président
malade et sur le fait qu' est-ce que la
maladie en parce que c'est ça la seule
vraie question empêche véritablement
d'exercer dans la plénitude toute sa
conscience ses fonctions c'est
passionnant c'est qu'effectivement on
sent qu'à la fois il n'y a pas de
réflexion et en même temps ils pressent
sans doute que ça peut l'empêcher
d'exercer le pouvoir veiller à mon avis
a pas un mensonge
il ya quand même une rémission est ce
que on a beau dire tout ce qu'on veut ça
a duré 14 ans 1 et 14 ans pendant
lesquels moi je l' ai vu crever les
journalistes qui le suivait il ya eu une
rémission à laquelle il a cru quand même
et si elle pas eu de révision ça
n'aurait pas duré aussi longtemps
donc ça ça me paraît c'est pas une
mission c'est pas un mensonge et à mon
avis c'est vraiment l'espoir que c'était
derrière lui bon et l'espoir a été
vaincue évidemment à partir de 92 au
moment où il a été obligé de se faire
opérer mais moi je me rappelle que
j'avais une émission à faire la première
émission à la télévision qu'il a fait
dans 80 c'était en décembre 80 et
j'étais en train dans le bureau avec
pierre des groupes et
j'ai roulé en train de d'aborder les
grands thèmes de l'émission puisqu'il a
poussé la porte et il a dit lequel de
vous me demande comment je vais alors on
s'est regardés que des groupes de combat
dire moi j'ose pas et donc c'est ainsi
que quand même et j'ai commencé
l'émission disant comment allez vous et
il a raconté qu'il a eue défaire
différents ennuis au début du mois de
septembre tant est que maintenant
c'était derrière lui et je crois qu'il
ne mentait pas à cette époque pierre
favier sur cette question sur sur sa
maladie vous ils vous l'avez vous le
disiez vraiment beaucoup fréquenté après
sa sortie de l'elysée a un moment où la
vraiment pour le coup il était il était
extrêmement affaibli au tout début de
son de son mandat en 1981 à quel moment
vous commencez à comprendre avoue douter
qu'il y a qu il y a un
à des soucis de santé oui donc je
voudrais revenir deux mots sur ce que
disait michèle cotta effectivement on
peut pas imaginer mitterrand en rendant
publique sa maladie sa maladie très
grave
à l'automne de 80 il faut se remettre
dans le contexte politique de l'époque
qui était quand même comment dire on a
une bataille frontale entre la droite et
la gauche c'est la première fois que la
gauche arriver au pouvoir depuis 25 ans
et imaginons que mitterrand annonce sa
maladie dès l'automne des dès le mois de
novembre 80 mais l'opposition qui était
quand même assez puissante et déterminés
à leur bout ce tunnel lui aurait demandé
de démissionner il était impossible à
mon avis politiquement d'annoncer sa
maladie à l'automne 80 c'est ou alors il
devait il devait partir il aurait été
contraint au départ et alors ce qui est
quand même extraordinaire c'est que les
les médecins le professeur steg de
cochin plus son médecin personnel lui
annonce la fin du mois d'octobre
au début du mois de novembre 80 qui les
frappe et d'un cancer de la prostate et
on lui donne maximum deux années de
survie et rendez vous compte que ce qui
s'est passé finalement jusqu'à 1992 et
il a pu gouverner en étant soignés sans
que cela ne pose le moindre problème de
l'exercice du pouvoir parce que je crois
que là-dessus c'est intéressant en 1994
quand vous le voilà vous continuez à a
conversé avec lui on lui propose de
prendre les antalgiques contre la
douleur et je crois que vous racontez
qu'il refuse d'en prendre car les ans
les effectivement à l'automne de 94
c'est le moment le plus difficile le
plus pénible pour lui parce qu'il est il
ya son cancer ce sens le sec le cancer
évolue mais ce qui est encore plus
difficile c'est qu'il est quand même
qu'il souffre d'oulu de ce cancer et à
longueur de journée il est dans la
douleur
alors dans cette période j'ai eu pas mal
de conversations avec lui dans son
bureau en fin de journée on et
allochtones 94 et il a il
confiez qui souffrait beaucoup hello et
spontanément je lui répondais
aujourd'hui les médecins sont capables
de soulager la douleur ils sont des
moyens de quatre baies et alors à chaque
fois là j'avais la même réponse de
françois mitterrand qui me disent on
peut peut-être ne soulage et calmer ma
douleur et des souffrances mais dans ce
cas là je pense que je n'aurais pu tous
mes esprits et je veux absolument garder
toute ma tête
voilà pourquoi je refuse les antalgiques
les médecins qui me propose et au bout
du compte il a fini par accepter que le
docteur tarot qui était un des
spécialistes des meilleurs spécialistes
du traitement de la douleur s'occupe de
lui à partir de la mi novembre 1994 et à
partir de là mitterrand était soigné
pour la douleur déjà le dire au
millimètre c'est intéressant là tu m'as
s'exercer là-dessus dominique bertinotti
me disais tout à l'heure qu'il est qu'il
craignait a effectivement voilà que la
maladie puissent avoir une influence sur
son sur son jugement vrai qu'on regarde
un extrait qui d'ailleurs n'a peut-être
pas grand-chose à voir avec la maladie
mais c'est l'un des tout derniers l'une
des toutes dernières prises de parole
publiques de françois mitterrand pendant
son mandat c'est le 8 mai 1995 et à ce
moment là il va obtenir des propos qui
sont des propos polémiques on regarde et
puis on en parle juste après je ne suis
pas venu célébrer la victoire
donc je me suis réjouie pour mon pays en
je ne suis pas venu souligner la défaite
parce que j'ai su ce qu'il y avait de
fortes le peuple allemand
ses vertus son courage et peu m'importe
ce d'uniformes et même l'idée qui
habitait l'esprit de ces soldats qui
allait mourir en si grand nombre
il était courageux
l'europe nous la faisons nous aimons nos
patries restons fidèles à nous-mêmes
reliant le passé et le futur et nous
pourrons passer l'esprit en paix le
témoin à ceux qui vont me suivre
voilà peu m'importe de l'idée qu'ils
habitaient ses soldats il parle des
soldats allemands pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale aura évidemment
aujourd'hui le ce genre de phrase aurait
sans doute pris des proportions
complètement différente là encore une
fois on a affaire à un homme extrêmement
affaibli la question est de savoir dans
quelle mesure à la à la fin de sa vie il
était parfaitement conscient de ce qu'il
disait michèle cotta il était tout à
fait conscient et depuis depuis assez
longtemps
quand je parlais tout à l'heure de
rémission c'est que je suis persuadé
mois 4,4 entre 81 date à laquelle elle a
dit y a un cancer
et puis 92 qui est quand même un il ya
dix ans dans lequel il s'est dit je m'en
sors je mens sera alors je pense qu'à
l'époque il souffrait beaucoup moins que
dans l'époque décrit évidemment dans le
film pierre favier
maintenant est ce que il l'avait
toujours en tête et depuis longtemps
l'idée de la mort comme vous savez dès
qu'un de ses amis était à l'hôpital où
des cannes et grasse et amis s'apprêtait
à mourir il était tout le temps là tout
le temps présent
l'appelant le réconfortant ça c'était
effectivement il ya toujours eu chez
mitterrand d'aidé de la main même pierre
favier d'un mot vous l'aviez suivi dans
ce déplacement
on vient de voir que à berlin oui à
berlin au mois de mai 95 oui
effectivement son son propos avait fait
polémique mais au bout du compte et
quand on le regarde
trente ans après on se rend compte que
ça s'inscrive est absolument dans la
démarche du général de gaulle qui en
1960 en 1963 avait signé avec le
chancelier adenauer un traité de
réconciliation franco-allemande et dans
la dent dans le discours de mitterrand
de 95 il ya cette volonté de
réconciliation qui est déjà en grande
partie accomplie
cette volonté de construction européenne
et il dit bon le passé ces guerres ont
été épouvantables de terribles
maintenant est venu le moment de la
réconciliation et de l'entente
franco-allemande dominique bertinotti
sur sur ce dernier discours sur voilà la
lucidité de françois mitterrand jusque
jusqu'au bout un talent et je pense que
c'était pour lui le le marqueur ultime
il n'aurait pas pu concevoir ne pas
avoir toutes ses facultés
intellectuelles jusqu'au bout ça c'était
pour avoir travaillé avec lui jusqu'au
bout avenue frédéric le play et donc
d'avoir puisqu'il travaillait à des
écrits dont l'exigence intellectuelle
était toujours là la rigueur
intellectuelle et était toujours là ce
que je voudrais dire sur cet extrait
qu'on voit d'abord c'est c'la c'est la
profondeur de la réflexion qui qui
impressionne dans la portée de ce
discours c'est à dire on voit bien que
c'est un discours aussi porté par un
homme qui sait que sa fin
malheureusement proche et qui a un
regard à la fois rétrospectif mais aussi
porteur d'un message d'avenir et ce lien
entre qu'il a toujours eu entre le passé
je veux dire aussi l'histoire il a un
rapport très très fort à l'histoire et
cette volonté aussi de dire que
l'histoire se poursuit et qu'elle
qu'elle trace on va laisser dans
l'histoire
et qu'est ce que les nouvelles
générations vont faire à la fois de cet
héritage
on le sent c'est un discours à mon avis
peut parler à des jeunes encore
aujourd'hui qui est vraiment inspirant
il avait conscience de fin de sa place
dans l'histoire mais depuis le début
depuis le début ça j'en suis pas sûr
enfin il a eu assez tôt dans sa vie je
vous pose la question parce qu'on revoit
dans l'évident amant les images
notamment du panthéon il arrive en 1981
il ya un sens on va dire c'est pour
celle de la liturgie républicaine ils
veulent marquer les esprits
on était d'abord marqué des esprits et
ensuite à partir surtout à partir du
moment où des oui les présidents et une
fois qu'il a gagné effectivement il veut
laisser au premier président à la
première présidence socialiste de la
vème république une marque est
évidemment il me semble que son
investiture et le panthéon c'est
évidemment une insigne symbole eh oui
les jeux commencent par honoré la
mémoire et les morts
mais elle entend t on oui le greta la
politique qui voulaient bien c'est sa
trace et alors et sans doute aussi dans
paris mais ça c'est une autre histoire
c'est maintenant devenu très très rare
dans l'actuelle classe politique mais
c'est quelqu'un françois mitterrand à
quelqu'un qui qui sait que et pas
simplement pour une question d'ego
personnel mais il s'inscrit dans une
histoire il est il est né lors de la
première guerre mondiale il a vécu la
seconde guerre mondiale il a vécu yalta
le partage du monde
je veux dire abandonner il n'est pas
passé comme ça donc il est nourri
et à la fois y compris de de son milieu
familial duquel il vient et c'est tout
cela qui au fond la cérémonie du
panthéon c'est déjà je dirais à une page
qui se tourne et qui est la traduction
de ce dont il a hérité lui même de ce
qui la conduit comme ensuite hommes
politiques comme principal celui qui va
porter la gauche au pouvoir
mais il sait qu'il s'inscrit dans une
dans une continuité historique qui est
qui et autres et d'où le choix aussi des
tombes sur lesquels dépose une rose à
l'intérieur du comté ce qui le traverse
qui le transcende il en est beaucoup
question dans le signe c'est assez
passionnant il ya notamment à une
expression qui revient à plusieurs
reprises les forces telluriques vrai
quand on regarde cette force de l'esprit
mais lui par les forces telluriques sont
étonnants regardez ce qu'en dit par
exemple georges kiejman qui
l'accueillait souvent chez lui à belle
île
bélisle il ne connaît pas et c'est un
paysage nouveau pour lui est de même
qu'il aurait plaisir à s'intéresser un
écrivain nouveau qui découvriraient il a
plaisir à découvrir un nouveau
territoire
il a fait des allusions force de
l'esprit il y avait quelque chose en lui
qui croyait une sorte de courants
telluriques qui venait de la terre et
pas seulement de l'esprit et à belle-ile
le côté tantôt doux tantôt sauvage tunes
sound
le résumé de la nature il à son chien
sur les talons il a quelques amis avec
lui il est au fond dans le bonheur d'une
sorte de paix qu'il ne trouverez nulle
part ailleurs à michèle cotta forces
telluriques voilà ce rapport à la terre
aux éléments c'est très présent chez les
c'est d'ailleurs dans son dernier voeux
aux français les forces de l'esprit de
dire je crois aux forces de l'esprit
je ne quitterai pas bien quand même dans
ce dans ses voeux aux français d'abord
une sorte de reconnaissance d'une vie
éternelle
il avait dit vous rappelez je suis né
pour être dit il avait dit je suis né
chrétien je mourrai chrétien mais dans
l'intervalle
bon donc il ya de sa part cette façon de
dire ce je ne vous quitterai pas reste
quand même très significatif un de ce
qu'ils pensent de la vie de la mort et
de la vie après la mort je ne vous
quitterai pas mais voilà en quoi ce
qu'il est encore présente et si l'on
reste aujourd'hui françois mitterrand
dominique bertinotti dans la dans la
pratique politique
ah j'allais dire je vais répondre
peut-être à la première partie de saison
qu'est ce qu'il en reste
et puis dans une après dans la pratique
politique aujourd'hui ce ce que
l'histoire retiendra sais c'est que
françois mitterrand a été capable de
porter pour des générations qui ne
connaissaient que la droite au pouvoir
qui ne voyait pas comment
être gouvernée par d'autres forces il
apportait la gauche au pouvoir et dont
tous les acquis sociaux en particulier
des années 80 83 les acquis sociétaux
que ce soit la peine de mort la retraite
à 60 ans enfin tout cela reste et a
construit à continuer à construire un
imaginaire collectif très fort
effectivement ensuite nous avons eu soit
un président rentable soit un président
experts et ça n'a plus grand chose à
voir avec l'essence même de la politique
l'essence même de la politique et c'est
pas qu'une question de changement de
société deux périodes de situation c'est
qu'il y a chez françois mitterrand qui
manque chez beaucoup de politiques
aujourd'hui une véritable réflexion sur
ce qu'est la politique
l'exercice du pouvoir j'ai assisté à
l'elysée à une réunion où il avait
convoqué tous ses conseillers ce qui
était excessivement rare et où il a tenu
une faille y avait 40 40 conseillers
il a tenu une véritable leçon de
politique de caisse que la politique
qu'est ce que la politique et c'est pas
le gouvernement des experts ou le
gouvernement des gestionnaires pierre
favier ce sera le mot de la fin sur cet
héritage de françois mitterrand héritage
de françois mitterrand ce bien compliqué
c'est bon à la fois l'alternance permise
possible et en même temps je pense le
message européen et l'action européenne
merci beaucoup merci à tous les trois
nous nous avoir éclairé je vais renvoyer
à vos livres respectifs dominique
bertinotti le jour où la gauche s'est
perdue c'est paru chez calmann lévy
pierre favier
l'ouvragé de référence bien sûr la
décennie mitterrand mais aussi dix jours
en mai paru en 2011 au seuil et michèle
cotta les cahiers secrets de la
cinquième république paraît dernièrement
chez fayard et puis je renvoie également
au monde selon mitterrand combat pensée
arrière pensée chez taillandier merci
encore merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
et à très bientôt sur public sénat
[Musique]